[Music]
[Applause]
miss me I think it's just kind of gave
up on that one huh whoa then we're whoa
Nellie
seem to be going for my son first well
then today's Thanks we're dodging a
harpoon for me I'm just gonna make my
way down here this weighs bombers ow
getting hurt
[Music]
well alright then ball throw all true it
is no I thought you were going in the
death there for a second oh come on
test my luck oh oh how you doing there
sir how you doing lovely today we're
having thanks for being my shield
I got a chair I mean I guess I'm playing
me now ha ha
hey a chair you can't defeat that's sure
this is slender the arrival HD wow it
actually looks really pretty okay how
how we've no now you're just insulting
me okay okay goodbye
thanks for the tentacle massage I did it
markiplier course all right I'll play oh
it was a trick see trick trick it's no
little buddy oh but I know how to beat
you oh that's that doesn't feel right
wait no hang on a minute I remember that
was there was a trick to this why is he
wailing Oh kids stop she's got enough
[Music]
block fall challenge I don't know what
that means
oh well this is an odd position but it's
oddly comfortable so I gotta start and
then move forward with whoa hey hey whoa
whoa whoa whoa Wow
let's go people freeze throw other
people of you this I could just get my
hand up this lady here huh yeah that's
normal
stand this here I'm gonna go for the
gentlemen first because obviously this
guy should could could I could I uh oh
that's gonna help me completely ow
come here you
that's better you go no not pause are
you good yes justice also good whoa whoa
Oh
go slowly ah all right kid it's time to
drop it off at school it's gonna be fine
[Music]
okay
yes I am still alive Oh spinning
whatever we doesn't hurt
okay only lost one leg and an arm
somewhere I don't know where that
happened rotating bottles what is that
what how is this a thing okay no my
drinking problems of the past have come
back to haunt me no oh it's the ghost of
booze past all right then that's okay
then that's also weird
did I win with no arms doing fine oh god
no please protect me perfecto Blake whoa
well that's okay that finished me off
whoo hee whoo whoo okay that's nice oh
okay you're going off a little more okay
I'll just stay here then and rest I'm
free but the price I paid does not seem
okay you really had to shoot me in the
shins my leg will okay my leg will
distract them after I when I return
you're really gonna go
axe run bro well that was easy
well that was easy well that was easy
well that was easy
well that was easy well that was easy Oh
[Music]
kill them all
level huh well bring it on you bastards
I've had tons of practice nope
excuse me sir did you miss your face Oh
nope you kill you you go over there trip
you up you lady oh that one got me
but you lovers just have a good old time
join you here
don't worry look son it's weird since
this is taking forever to load check out
this cool shirt I got it packs marking
the pliers real good thank you so much
for the present
marklar death row well in case you
didn't know whoa whoa whoa whoa oh I get
it now I gotta just hear you and not the
baby cuz okay leg broken but I'm okay
don't kill the kid up don't kill the
pineapples baby
okay pineapples okay oh that gave me
more Swartz killing a baby last time was
man Wow
thank you Mary knows markiplier special
here we go is this supposed to be I'm
sorry I think we should see other people
Oh gently like a butterfly oh I got okay
that did not help me it oh whoa okay it
ain't gonna baby
okay this did not end well for me why'd
you freeze don't freeze on me first try
to Marga by our explosion yeah you're
not even pretending to pretend that this
is impossible
whoa bye miss med douche well I'm
leaving now my people need me on Zargon
okay why is that he'll dead but still
one we gotta save the kitty marks a
black tree I'm Sarah
[Music]
good job just a them this has been happy
wheels highlights thanks for watching if
you want to see more happy wheels right
now check the description or click the
annotation for the full happy wheels
playlist and if you want to see more
happy wheels in the future please click
the like button to let me know thanks
again everyone and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye